it's a beautiful day in this
neighborhood and a beautiful day for a
neighborhood would you be fine
[Music]
generations of children including this
one started their day hearing fred
rogers sing that song at the start of
every episode of Mister Rogers
neighborhood the groundbreaking series
spoke directly to kids about some of
life's way Dias issues in a simple and
direct fashion the new documentary won't
you be my neighbor looks at the legacy
of Fred Rogers and his Emmy
award-winning program it opened this
week here's a peek
he had a director that once said to me
you take all of elements that make good
television and do the exact opposite you
have mr. Rogers neighborhood low
production values simple set an unlikely
star
yet they worked
because he was saying something really
important love is at the root of
everything all learning all parenting
all relationships love or the lack of it
Academy award-winning filmmaker Morgan
Nevel directed the documentary and is
with us now good morning good morning
this was wonderful and Vlad said he
watched I watched what made you want to
do this film well I was a child once I
watched the show and I loved the show as
a child and then I didn't think about
him for a long time
but then as a parent myself and
rediscovering him
I sensed there was a lot more to him
than I ever realized and as I made the
film I realized there was so much more
than I realized what was the biggest
thing that you realized about him that
you didn't know he was doing something
profound something deep he was helping
kids process life figure out how to deal
with the trauma being a person in our
culture he really was doing something
that worked on multiple levels at the
same time it was simple but not
superficial was very simple but very
deep you know I watch a lot of those
children's shows Sesame Street and
romper room and The Electric Company but
there was something unique about Mister
Rogers neighborhood that those shows did
not have as amazing as they were well he
was a Presbyterian minister first of all
so he never mentioned God but there was
an element of ministry to what he was
doing he was basically telling kids this
is how you should treat each other and
this is how you should treat yourselves
I mean the idea of a neighborhood is
kind of our society how are we gonna
live together so these fundamental
messages of morality and kindness you
know I like to think of his message
essentially as radical kindness right
but the issues on Mister Rogers
neighborhood were weightier
then you might find on a Sesame Street
which was all about counting and you
know words and numbers yeah I think
about Sesame Street as a place he would
go to learn about numbers or counting
and you would have Schoolhouse Rock
would teach you about civics which are
great but what mr. Rogers was doing was
teaching about being a person
it's almost a moral show in that way so
he was looking at these profound issues
of death and war and divorce and this is
a show for 2 to 6 year olds yeah I don't
think at the time we clearly didn't
realize we did not was when you watch
the documentary and see so many of those
things it also surprised me how involved
he was in the production how like
hearted he was I maybe didn't
necessarily expect that in him it's it's
interesting because on the one hand he
wrote every episode he wrote every song
he did the voice the voices of all the
puppets see I mean he was deeply
involved in the show and he was kind of
a perfectionist about it and a little
bit of a you know struggling artist
trying to figure it out but at the same
time he had this incredible sense of
humor he was so funny and that was a big
revelation to me the revelation to me
was as a kid I loved the land of
make-believe and I didn't realize that
he was the principal puppeteer for all
those puppets until I realized he was
never very so that was a big revelation
for me but the other one I want to know
is what was he like in real life
was he the same I mean nobody is but did
he bring some of those attribute that's
the thing it's the fundamental question
that everybody wants to know is he for
real
there's kids but write in and say are
you for real you know I think the answer
is yes I mean he is oddly almost exactly
who mr. Rogers the character is you know
and in fact I think in real life he was
a more impressive person even than the
character you know more willful more
intellectual more just human but he was
mr. Rogers there was nothing I found out
about him that was shocking but it was
all surprising he died only a couple
years after doing the show did he
realize at the time of his death from
what you could find out the impact that
he had on generations well children I
mean at one point he was getting as much
mail as anybody in America and he
responded to every letter so he received
over a million pieces of mail over his
career so there's no way he couldn't
have known but I don't think he ever
felt secure that he had done done a good
job and you know it was time to retire
he always felt there was more he could
do goes back to childhood if you watch
the documentary UCLA yeah
yeah I want to ask you two it's one last
question about the man who played
officer Clemens Francois Clemens he was
gay
what did Fred Rogers think about that
Fred was supportive of gay rights but he
didn't want Francois to be openly gay on
a children's TV show in the late 1960s
and it was something he struggled with
and I think it was difficult he came
around on it but it took a long time but
it showed that he himself was human that
he made mistakes and I think he did
admit that such a fascinating
documentary documentary your work is
always incredible and it's so great to
be able to talk to you when you ever you
have these pieces thank you so much for
coming on thanks for having me Morgan
Neville so great will you be my neighbor
is currently playing in theaters around
the nation